6 millions c'est le nombre de français
touchés par l'arthrose cette maladie
dégénérative qui peut devenir un
véritable problème au quotidien et
empêcher l'utilisation de certains
membres
aujourd'hui la prise en charge n'est pas
toujours adapté en france le dr
christian couturier spécialiste de la
main à trappes a donc décidé d'ouvrir
une clinique pour soigner cette maladie
qui touche principalement les personnes
âgées un établissement
pluridisciplinaire doit ainsi ouvrir ses
portes d'ici à quelques mois montigny le
bretonneux reportage de à camille
lambert tenir un objet se brosser les
dents des gestes du quotidien souvent
douloureux et parfois même impossible
pour les malades atteints d'arthrose de
la main mais pour le docteur christian
couturier chirurgien de la main à
trappes
ce n'est pas une fatalité il a décidé de
créer une clinique adaptée à la prise en
charge de cette maladie
on entend dire sans arrêt nos
consultations que celles âgées qui a
rien à faire et malheureusement c'est
pas vrai il ya plein de choses pour
soulager les patients soulager la
douleur conserver la fonction c'est un
projet très innovant parce que à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas d'autres
établissements en france dédiée à la
prise en charge de l'arthrose de la main
et du membre supérieur dédié à une prise
en charge pluridisciplinaire et pluri
médecine et avec un protocole
d'évaluation de toutes ces prises en
charge un établissement polyvalent qui
regroupera différents spécialistes
médecins chirurgiens mais aussi
ostéopathe acupuncteur ou naturopathe
des médecines alternatives bien connu du
docteur françois brouchoud cela fait
trois ans qu'il travaille en france et
en chine
on a des hôpitaux ou en post opératoire
il n'y a pas de traitement allopathique
où on est sûr de la médecine
traditionnelle avec et très vraiment de
médecine traditionnelle
l'acupuncture et les massages
traditionnels et les gens n'ont pas plus
mal et ils ont des chirurgies qui sont
exactement identique à la nôtre dans ne
crée pas un cent de médias alternatifs
pas du tout c'est une c'est un centre
pour prendre soin du patient et chaque
patient d'avoir une affinité différentes
à des différents praticiens ou technique
et je pense que le point fort sa dette
justement la collaboration entre de ces
différentes techniques et pas simplement
les opposer c'est le travail en
collaboration
une première en france qui ouvrira à
montigny le bretonneux à l'automne 2010
est la clinique pourrait accueillir sept
à dix mille personnes par an six
millions de français sont touchés par
l'arthrose